we've all been processing the incredible
leak that the supreme court is planning
to issue a decision which will overturn
roe v wade and planned parenthood
v casey in the next few weeks these are
the main two
decisions on which abortion being
typically legal in most cases without an
undue burden in the united states are
based that's going to be overturned and
we've talked about the legal aspects of
it we've talked about what did the
justices that are believed to be in
favor of this decision how did they
answer questions about abortion during
their supreme court confirmation
hearings we've talked about this as an
unfettered victory for trumpism i mean
trump who's not even really pro life i
mean we at age 68 he came up with this
thing oh i met a kid and i liked him and
the mom thought about an abortion so now
i'm pro-life it's all bs the guy's not
even pro-life and yet he now has
achieved one of the greatest victories
for the anti-abortion movement we've
talked about all of that
the next question which many of you have
been asking is well
what happens now to individuals in
states where you might want to go
and obtain an abortion and that is
exactly what i'm going to talk about
here first i want to tell you real quick
about our sponsor art list if you make
any kinds of videos whether it's a hobby
or a career you need access to great
music and sound effects and when the
david pakman show needs music and sound
effects we only go to art list our team
has been using art lists for years long
before they became a sponsor even our
channel trailer on the front page of
youtube uses artless music we've looked
at all sorts of music platforms and we
chose art list because of the selection
affordability and a lot more freedom
than with other services because when
you subscribe to art list you can use
any song or sound effect from their
massive catalog as many times as you
want for any project worldwide and
royalty free on all the other stock
sites i've looked at you have to pay per
song
and there's a bunch of limitations art
list gives you the power to use as many
songs as you want however many times you
want
most stock music sites have low quality
generic songs that sound mass-produced
but everything on art list is rich it's
dynamic
everything's downloadable as ultra high
quality audio files you can search with
a ton of different filters to find
exactly the type of song you were
thinking of the library is huge and
growing all of the music is produced by
independent artists and art list
actually pays the musicians well which
is really important artlist has music
and sound effects plans starting as low
as 9.99 a month and you'll get two extra
months for free when you use my link
down below
okay so here's the deal
to be perfectly frank
about how bad this abortion decision is
for people who currently live and will
continue living in blue states
probably nothing will change those
states will continue to have a legal
abortion
and
there might be more antagonism from the
anti-abortion movement
of people availing themselves of these
services but legally it is likely that
nothing will change
in the red states that have already
passed abortion ban so these are places
like mississippi
kentucky we talked about oklahoma those
are going to be upheld
assuming
assuming what we are beyond the
overturning of roe v wade and planned
parenthood versus casey those are going
to be upheld and it will become
extraordinarily difficult to obtain an
abortion we talked about oklahoma with a
six-week ban
most women don't know they're pregnant
until week four or five at minimum so it
is effectively a total ban
it's also important to remember that
there are red states that don't have
anti-abortion laws on the books yet
nothing will change in those states
immediately on the basis of the supreme
court decision but it will open the door
to those states going and saying well
now that the supreme court has
overturned roe v wade and planned
parenthood vkc let's now pass uh a bill
into law
that will make abortion that much more
difficult to obtain so it's not good
news in fact it's disastrous news but i
do think it's important just to
sort of remind
that things don't instantly change at
the state level now the other aspect of
this that we have to consider and i
mentioned this when we first covered the
story and based on all the coverage and
things i've read since then
i am more convinced that this is going
to be the case they're not going to stop
with this
now i'm not saying everyone who's
against abortion is against gay marriage
interracial marriage divorce wants to be
able to legally fire people for their
real or perceived sexual orientation or
whatever but there is overlap between
those groups these are groups that want
to go back they want to go back to the
1950s or the 1850s or medieval times or
who knows when they want to go back to
invigorated by this major victory and it
is a major victory for them
we have to just accept that it's a major
victory for them
they aren't going to stop here
so almost certainly we are going to see
some next frontier here and it will
maybe be based along the lines of
religious freedom
so-called religious freedom maybe it
will be based on this new idea that now
samuel alito in his leaked decisions as
it was wrongly decided to begin with
and it is opening the door
to a total lack of respect for precedent
remember that during their supreme court
confirmation hearings gorsuch and
kavanaugh you know they all paid lip
service to
precedent precedence important precedent
president president and here they are
all voting to overturn roe v wade so
this will not be the last frontier uh
and there will be some really tough
decisions for people to make about where
do you want to live do you want to live
in a state with laws that feel like
medieval times
or do you want to live in a state that
is
entering
something that might approximate the
modern day
lots of questions about that and we're
going to continue covering all of it of
course